und wir sind mittendrin in der frage
macht die ampel gute politik oder nicht
und das ist auch die überleitung zu
johannes arlt dem
spd-bundestagsabgeordneten und ihrem
thema heute abend ja also ich hab mich
diese woche sehr geärgert über die
medien berichterstattung zum thema
ukraine ist einfach so dass wir als ja
als unsicherer kantonist angestellt
werden das ärgert mich weil wir sind der
zweitgrößte geber weltweiten die ukraine
wir haben seit 2014 1,8 milliarden euro
in dieses land investiert wir haben auch
militärisch mit einem feldlazarett
unterstützt aber ich glaube einfach dass
das vielfach daran liegt dass wir
schneller kommunizieren könnten klarer
kommunizieren können wenn wir eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie hätten
wenn wir wüssten was wir wirklich wollen
wo wir stehen um einen solchen
sicherheitspolitischen krisen wirklich
schneller und kohärenter auch agieren zu
können dazu gehören auch einsatzbereite
streitkräfte die er unser land
verteidigen können unsere bürger
verteidigen können damit man auch diese
fielen steuer euros die in die
streitkräfte investieren die bürger auch
was zurück bekommen nämlich eine echte
leistung die mehr sicherheit bringt ganz
im sinne eines beitrags der
friedenspolitik im 21 jahrhundert
habe ich sie da war richtig verstanden
hat das ist jetzt ja doch etwas weiter
gehend dass sie werbung machen dafür
dass die bundeswehr auch bei
beispielsweise einem russischen
zusätzlichen einmarsch in der ukraine
dann auch parat stehen soll und dort
eingreift eingreifen soll wir sind an
einer nato solche dinge entscheiden wer
nicht alleine da gibt es in artikel 5
und die ukraine ist kein nato-mitglied
ja und ich trete ja auch nicht dafür
einen wir haben in deutschland tradition
dass wir sagen wir wir setzen auf die
macht des wortes setzen auf diplomatie
und das wird ja oft ganz ganz
verschiedenen kanälen gemacht dass wir
dort sprechen und jeder tag an dem wir
sprechen gibt es keine bewaffnete
auseinandersetzungen schon mal ein guter
tag aber ist nicht weil sie das jetzt
gerade sagten und mich hat der auftritt
von olaf scholz in washington doch
durchaus ehrlich gesagt
empört dass ein deutscher bundeskanzler
nicht in der lage ist das wort nord
stream zwei als möglichen sanktions
gronau gab einmal in den mund zu nehmen
oder stolz hat es geschafft die wenigen
stunden die an washington war knapp 24
aber das wort nord stream zwei nicht ein
einziges mal
auszusprechen und ich glaube das ist
auch das was sie sagten die hilfen die
wir der ukraine geleistet haben sie
haben ein militärisch überhaupt nichts
mit militär in überhaupt nichts zu tun
das ist hilfe beispielsweise in der
energiepolitik hilfe für gutes regieren
wenn man sich anschaut
er ging aus deutschland waffen im wert
von fast zehn milliarden in die welt
hinaus unterarm nach ägypten in diesem
militärdiktatur nach ukraine gegen kein
einziges keine einzige waffe kein
einziger euro dann fragt man sich doch
wo ist da eigentlich die
verhältnismäßigkeit warum sträubt sich
vor allem die spd eigentlich so stark
waffen in die ukraine zu liefern ich
finde das bild was die ampel aber
speziell auch ihre partei abgibt das
sage ich unverblümt die schätze sie ja
aber ihre partei abgibt das ist
beschämend
ich finde das nicht bestimmt ich finde
das gut dass wir keine kriegswaffen in
krisengebiete liefern das ist doch ist
nein wir liefern keine kriegswaffen in
krisengebieten rüstungsexport ja ägypten
darüber kann man streiten und die als
appell haben uns vorgenommen das zu
ändern diese regeln zu überarbeiten dass
auch strenger zu machen da muss man auch
darüber reden wie diese industrie die 45
400.000 arbeitsplätze in deutschland
auch bereitstellt gut bezahlte
arbeitsplätze wie die und zukunft
natürlich auch überleben können und
welche möglichkeiten die haben auch für
ihre produkte ab das heißt das wenn ich
keine waffen aber nur kurz machen dafür
keine waffen in krisengebiete liefern
warum liefer ich dann eigentlich waffen
warum brauche ich eine armee also ich
verstehe das bisher so dass sich
demokratien mit ihren waffen mit ihren
armeen wehren können wenn wir jetzt
sagen wir beliefern eine demokratie die
von einem aggressor bedroht wird und die
russland ist ein aggressor putin ist ein
aggressor bedroht wird dann sagen wir
lieber aggressoren du darfst dazu
schlagen weil wir in so ein krisengebiet
um eine demokratie wie die ukraine zu
schützen keine waffen liefern und dort
nicht helfen diese logik die ist doch
dies doch bekloppt und es hat noch mal
so zu sagen würde ich so nicht sehen am
meer immer eine abschreckungspotenzial
einsatzbereite streitkräfte eine
abschreibung des schreckens potenzial
was ihm auch hilft und diplomatischen
bühne entsprechend seine forderung
weiter voranzutreiben also
einsatzbereite streitkräfte die gut
ausgerüstet sind die ein hohes
fähigkeitsspektrum haben die helfen eben
gerade bewaffnete konflikte zu vermeiden
und darum hat man sie ja auch aber das
ist genau der punkt warum helfen wir den
jetzt nicht der ukraine ein
abschreckungspotenzial aufzubauen um
sozusagen militärische kosten für
russland zu erhöhen damit genau das dazu
beiträgt dass russland zurück schreckt
davor hier irgendwie zu wie diesen
diesen ukraine krieg und genau das tun
wir im rahmen der nato wir haben noch
2014 nach der krim krise überall die
matthews aufgestellt also haben überall
multinationale kommandos in den kleinen
ländern am rand der nato aufgestellt um
zu sagen hier sind 27 nationen die haben
ein paar soldaten greifst du jemanden an
greift uns alle an wir schicken jetzt
hier verdoppeln jetzt und dann beitrag
in litauen dementsprechend an soldaten
und leisten dafür in haan server
personen schutz der aussengrenzen
unseren beitrag die ukraine ist kein
nato-mitglied wir tun auf diplomatischer
ebene alles um der ukraine zu helfen
also ich meine partei ist ja auch teil
der ampel ich sehe in dem punkt
tatsächlich anders ich glaube wir
sollten die ukraine auch mit waffen
unterstützen mich überzeugt dass nicht
zu sagen in dem moment wo eine
feindliche armee an seiner grenze steht
bist du ein potenzieller konfliktherd
und dann dürfen wir keine waffen mehr
liefern sondern gerade dann müssen wir
doch so ein land unterstützen und ich
glaube auch tatsächlich dass es ein
beitrag zur friedenssicherung ist die
wehrhafte die ukraine ist ein kleines
land von dem überhaupt keine bedrohung
ausgeht dass einem großen russischen
aggressor gegenüberstehen die wehrhafte
diese ukraine ist je höher der preis für
wladimir putin wäre wenn er sagt wir
machen da jetzt einen angriff auf dieses
land desto unwahrscheinlicher wird
dieser angriff ist so wahrscheinlicher
bleibt ist beim frieden und deswegen
glaube ich ich finde gut dass wir die
ukraine finanziell unterstützen ich
würde auch gut wie die außenministerin
berbalk momentan der auftritt aber wir
sollten auch militärgerät dorthin
liefern also wir haben ja militärgerät
das hat nicht nur die 5000 helfer
sondern wir haben militärgerät wir haben
doch einen feldhospital hin geliefert
einziger modernsten geräten die auch
hohen gefechts wert haben
dementsprechend was mobiles verlegt wahr
ist wir bei haben 180 schwer verwundete
ukrainische soldaten unserem bundeswehr
krankenhäusern behandelt bereits was ich
nicht verstehen kann ist das quasi die
alten nva kanonen die jetzt irgendwie
zentrum stehen an die ukraine geliefert
werden ist das kein problem aber ist das
wirklich etwas legerer sehen da stimme
ich zu und andere länder denen die jetzt
gehört nicht behindern auch wenn die mal
ursprünglich vor 20 jahren oder 30
jahren von uns kamen aber ansonsten
finde ich sollte mir daran festhalten
waffen in krisengebiete
die bringen nichts anhaben die usa auch
sehr schlechte erfahrungen gemacht aber
er alt wenn ich das einfach noch mal
fragen darf sie beschweren sich gerade
darüber dass wir als deutsche in der
welt plötzlich so einen schlechten ruf
haben weil wir offenbar als unsicherer
kantonist gelten und wenn ich jetzt
überlege die amerikaner keiner hat lust
mit einem auf eine militärische
auseinandersetzung mit russland ganz
klar jetzt hören deutschland schickt
5000 helme und hat ein militärlazarett
gebaut und 180 verwunderte aufgenommen
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der ein
oder andere auch ihrer amerikanischen
kameraden bisschen schmunzelt und sagt
mensch auf der welt sind unsere ganzen
flugzeugträger unterwegs wir sind in
verschiedenen krisengebieten im einsatz
da sterben soldaten
weil sie die freiheit verteidigen und
ihr erzählt uns was das ihr 180
verwundete soldaten aufgenommen habt ein
bisschen mismatch ist aber auch eine
andere gewichtsklasse amerika als wir
auch sicherheitspolitisch das müssen wir
auch sehen dabei und so einfällt
hospital es ist ein substanzieller
beitrag und trotzdem können wir halt
unserer linie treu bleiben und die haben
wir schon seit der wiedervereinigung
dass wir eben dort keine waffen liefern
ist einmal gemacht bei den page merga
ist auch jetzt keine erfolgsgeschichte
die waffen die räder geliefert haben und
ich bin der meinung da sollte man sich
nicht verzetteln aber es war auch
richtig dass wir die peschmerga
unterstützt haben also wir reden jetzt
über die über die irakischen kurden die
sich dort gegen die es verteidigt haben
die dort auch die jesiden geschützt
haben vor der versklavung durch den erst
ich glaube es war doch vernünftig die
militärische auszurüsten grundsätzlich
ist das grundsätzlich ist natürlich
absolut richtig gewesen die zu
unterstützen aber ob die art der
unterstützung die richtige war darüber
konnte man sicherlich diskutieren haben
sie sorge vor einem krieg dass putin die
ukraine richtig überfällt ich habe unten
noch nicht mal unbedingt so viel sorge
für die ukraine ich habe auch für unser
eigenes land sorge denn ich sehe das
problem ganz anders das kernproblem ist
auch wie ist unsere bundeswehr überhaupt
aufgestellt also wenn man da glaube ich
mal unsere waffenlager schaut und die
rüstung
materialien sich ansieht wie sie derzeit
da sind dann ist das glaube ich
hochgradig peinlich ich weiß gar nicht
wie viele funktionsträger kampfjets
haben wir dann überhaupt die inzwischen
sogar daran heute schon recht viele aber
diese haben sie haben sie haben völlig
recht in diesem völlig recht also ich
war im geschwader letzten donnerstag und
die haben zeitlichen klar stand geht es
von 80 prozent mit den eurofightern er
und sich schon stabile an also das wird
besser jetzt nach 15 jahren immerhin ist
natürlich auch lächerlich aber sie haben
völlig recht und viele dinge die auf der
wunschliste der ukraine stehen die wir
gerne hätten haben wir selber nicht
ausreichendem auswählen noch mal ein
anderes thema nämlich auch da mit
einbringen kurz mal abgesehen von kriegs
bedrohung die natürlich jetzt irgendwo
im raum steht wenn wir einfach mal
drüber nachdenken wofür brauchen für die
bundeswehr im land und auch eine gute
rüstung für diese bundeswehr im land
dann brauchen wir die ganz einfach auch
für solche profane dinge wie ein
generalisierten stromausfall ja wenn wir
jetzt mal einen anschlag hätten und der
strom ist weg auch da brauchen wir
unsere bundeswehr um unser eigenes land
am laufen zu halten und da sind im
moment überhaupt nicht in der lage zu
also ich find auch manchmal bevor wir
anfangen bei anderen ländern und sehr
groß gedanken zu machen vielleicht
räumen wir erst mal intern ein bisschen
auf und stellen uns auf denn
grundsätzlich ist gut wenn man etwas
macht aber er macht man es ganz und
richtig oder gar nicht und helme zu
schicken es halt auch vielleicht
annehmen es ist einmalig so richtig und
gar nicht das ist ein wirklich sehr
gutes schlusswort an diesem heutigen
dienstag abend meine damen und herren
vor den bildschirmen und auch meine
damen meine herren hier im studio ganz
herzlichen dank für diese wirklich
lebhafte diskussion es hat wahnsinnig
viel spaß gemacht ich freue mich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn sie morgen abend
wieder einstellen und natürlich es gibt
den neuen viertel nach acht newsletter
den sollten sie sich auf jeden fall
holen ganz herzlichen dank fürs
zuschauen ich hoffe es hat ihm so viel
spaß gemacht wie uns hier im studio
haben sie einen schönen abend bis bald
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]